Rick Ross's son William Roberts III
decided to turn down offers from Power
five schools like Colorado and Miami and
committed to bethon cookman University
instead the Daytona Beach HBCU finished
their previous season 3 and8 and are
looking to improve their record now that
they have the 6'2 270lb Garden Center on
their team William was a starter for his
high school at St Thomas aquinus and he
is now one of the over 150 players at
the school sented D1 programs Williams's
talent definitely runs in the family
because Rick Ross also played college
football for a little while and also
played center when he attended the HBCU
Albany State University in the 9s